you mentioned that
Ayahuasca reveals
oh boy oh no the
the darkness that's there in the in the
jungle
there's Beauty but there's Darkness so
what is it what is it that I Oscar
reveals what is the Heart of Darkness
[__] it opens the Heart of Darkness
right up
um um I'm gonna show you a picture of
him of our Shaman and then I'm gonna ask
if you want to do Ayahuasca here not
here in that sense it can only be done
in the jungle anybody that tells you
I've heard people be like oh I did
Ayahuasca in Brooklyn last week and I'm
like no you didn't
I actually told that to my native
friends I went hey guess what I said a
bunch of Gringos keep thinking they're
doing Ayahuasca in Brooklyn and they
were like howling laughing they're like
you can't do it outside the jungle and I
was like exactly I've never done
Ayahuasca I would love to have uh I've
done or eaten whatever mushrooms sure
it's it's a wonderful experience I think
it's wonderful um but ayahuasca
oh man yeah see I had done mushrooms I
thought I was like okay and I I I yeah I
was like I got this I had my notebook I
was like I'm gonna Journal a little bit
yeah you know and then but but you
quickly I quickly quickly realized how
out of my depth I was and how unprepared
I was for what was happening because you
sit in a circle with these native guys
and there's one you know he's got the
feathers and he's old and he's got a
face like the map of the world and he's
he's smoking this fat old tobacco thing
and
he calls you forward and you kneel
before him and you're going
is it too late to back up and everyone's
you know there's one candle and he blows
smoke over the over the cup and he hands
it to you and you're like again it's
these it's these it's these
like these things that you can't argue
with it's these facts like as soon as
this goes down I'm gone I know it and
this is a moment in my life that I I
have to either embarrass myself in front
of everybody or I'm going forward with
this and dish
and then I went and sat
you're sitting in the dark and it's
again so we're on a platform with a with
palm thatched roof and the jungle is all
around you so all those Millie tens of
millions of frogs and insects are and
I'm like all right cool and I remember I
like you know like I tried to like light
a cigarette or something and I went oh
that's not gonna happen you know and
then I and I I put my hands on the floor
and like my experience I mean like we've
done mushrooms you know it's like it's
it's interesting it's introspective
no this this was like somebody unzipped
the Universe I I you know I spent a lot
of without you boring people with it I
spent a lot of time in in in like
unconstructed dream space like floating
between nebulas like there was a long
period where there was no physical shape
where I lived without a name and like so
it's like it's like you get brought so
deep down so elementally lost in the
universe where like I truly felt like I
was experiencing moving through places
like like that like that uh like that
um asteroid that I have like it's it's
like a piece of your pure piece of
something detached from the earth and so
I I got back from it and uh
had a interesting new appreciation for
Life uh I strongly suggest that people
just do mushrooms like a normal person
unless you unless you're ready so it was
really intense it was really intense but
to be fair the shaman who did it was
like the old school guy yeah and he was
he was getting up there in years and he
had forgotten and over boiled The Brew
yeah and so we came back and I was like
four in the morning and I had you know
all this crazy [__] I'd been on Journeys
and years down there and so when I came
back and I had like hands I started
crying I started absolutely weeping
gratitude gratitude that I was alive I
was gonna get to see my people again I
was like I have to see my parents again
yeah I'm gonna get to talk I thought you
might have been gone I was gone I was
gone I was I was a I was a dimly
conscious something floating in dark
space and spent what felt like years
down there and so when I I really did
feel like being reborn which I was like
Cheap Trick like yeah you
um but no the the the the way it moves
You Through the Jungle the way the
jungle moves through your skin
there are moments of absolute majesty
and incredible discovery that happened
along the way
um and on the way up the jungle brings
you up and and the shaman brings you up
and and you and you get to move through
the forest in a way that
it's almost like you're inhabiting the
consciousness of animals very very very
like I didn't think that hallucinogenics
could do this to it to a brain you know
mushrooms you're like oh I can I feel
like I can feel music like really cool
you know you guys want to watch the
Penguins
this is transformative like what yeah
did that did that change you I don't
know I think it definitely it definitely
I I almost feel like it showed me the
thing that I was scared the most of and
it's that it was like that it's all just
cold dark nothing it like brought me to
like the basement of the universe
and I felt like the point of that was to
to come back to this place where there's
all this life and light and love and and
all this amazing stuff that we
experience on a day-to-day basis and
don't take for granted and so just like
almost dying this was like fully dying
like they're you know but the great part
is is that usually it's not that intense
this guy had over boiled The Brew he had
also I saw the vine afterwards most
Ayahuasca Vines are like as thick as
your arm this one was like as thick as a
garbage can it was like the oldest
Ayahuasca Vine you can imagine
and at like four in the morning I like
crawled over to my friend Chris who's a
tough New York City firefighter we were
like holding each other just like
weeping just like thank God we're back
and uh
then we had to go looking for the shaman
well where the hell is this guy he's
gone yeah we found him in the morning
and he was laying in the Stream naked
like E.T at the end when he's like
laying like in the yeah he he kicked his
own ass with that brew and he retired
after that oh [__] so we really got like
we somebody turned the dial all the way
up on us and so we got we got blasted so
it's not supposed to be that bad
but I think you're somebody who's
Fearless in sort of diving into those
kinds of places I think I also retire
from Ayahuasca I could be Fearless with
other things but I think I'm good
it sounds kind of uh to me personally
kind of exciting
well I think I think that you have a
severely Fearless aspect to you I mean
you're
when you come up with something that
intrigues you like if somebody told you
right now that you could go
physically into deep space I feel like
you would do it yeah I do yeah if go to
Mars yeah right and some of it is
I don't even know if you have that
some of that is more Goggins like I want
to see where my mind breaks by pushing
it to
tough places
there's a curiosity of exploring the
mind the limits of the mind I feel like
it's not a cold plunge that's like
you're not coming back right
right and that's that's okay
ah see no I have I I do I have
I I'm with you on that I love seeing my
limits I absolutely love seeing my
limits I love getting my ass kicked I
love being shown how insignificant I am
but when it comes to something like that
where you got to push your chips in it's
got to be something for me it's got to
be a hill that I believe in before I die
on it and it's like
like to me the the promise of exploring
space isn't enough but
like even just the way I mean you said
you're like I'm going to Ukraine here I
go
you know there's a certain
um
dedication to to curiosity
at any expense
and I think that that is something that
maybe we share in very in in different
directions
something tells me without with those
with those crocodiles outside I would
have gotten eaten something tells me
there's some something trying to
preserve you in this world I'm not sure
exactly what that is
somehow you keep surviving